while the original PlayStation VR was an
admirable first effort for Sony it was
also an awkward piece of Hardware it
launched when consumer Focus headsets
were in their nasancy which is probably
why Sony could get away with a
jerry-rigged chimera of old and new
technology psvr felt like a solution
hurriedly thrown together to make the
most of an emerging Trend its successor
the PlayStation VR2 is the opposite in
almost every way it's a thoughtfully
designed piece of Hardware that is
powerful and delivers a user-friendly
plug-and-play experience that is almost
entirely frictionless the technology
powering it is modern making it a worthy
companion to the PlayStation 5 and it
sense controllers are designed
specifically for gaming in VR spaces the
psvr2 is undoubtedly a major step
forward for PlayStation's virtual
reality Ambitions and it's one of the
best headsets on the market but in the
ever shifting landscape or virtual
reality its price and current value
proposition leave it in an awkward
position once again out of the box the
psvr 2 looks and feels like a premium
piece of tech technology the matte white
on deep black PlayStation color scheme
is replicated here to great effect and
the form factor swaps the sharpness of
the PS5 for rounded corners and curved
Bands That Make the whole unit pleasing
to look at as well as put on and take
off the sense controllers are similarly
elegant in design comfortably filling my
hands and allowing my fingers and thumbs
to rest on the buttons and triggers very
naturally the original psvr was loaded
as being the most comfortable headset on
the market and psvr2 can also claim
their Accolade as it's even more
comfortable to wear it may feel a little
heavy for those who are used to the
lighter meta Quest too but the way it
feels well distributed so I didn't have
the neck fatigue issues that I feared
May crop up during longer sessions there
also some brilliant little product
design features in the PSV R2 that when
you hear about don't seem like a big
deal but make all the difference when
using the headset on a day-to-day basis
one such example is the headphones that
are included with the headset which plug
into the band and have a thin plastic
body that Contours around the band so it
doesn't even look like a separate piece
until the ends where a small stretch of
wire and inner headphones Dangle on
either side of the band are too indents
that you can push the headphones into to
safely hold them in place like little
finger traps it's easy to put the
headphones in take them out and store
them without ever removing the headset
this kind of care and consideration put
into Comfort extends to the more
essential parts of the experience on the
front of the headset is a button that
easily lets you move the lenses towards
and away from the face another button on
the back serves as a similar function
for the band which means it's very easy
to slide the headset on and have it fit
comfortably the mixture of hard plastic
and cushions give the psvr to a
sturdiness and comfort that other
headsets relying on straps can't match
on the Quest 2 you need to pay extra for
the comfort by buying a headband once
the psvr2 headset is on it's easy to
make adjustments to find The Sweet Spot
that works for you a dial on the front
moves the spacing of the two internal
lenses so you can better align them with
your eyes while another on the back
tightens the band to secure it to your
head similar to how it worked with the
original setting up the psvr2 is a
breeze which is a far cry from the
original headset's mess-off cables
cameras and breakout boxes this time
around it's as simple as plugging a
single wire into the front of the PS5
each sense controller must be physically
plugged into the console via the USB
port but that's just once to pair them
from there the PS5 recognizes that a
psvr2 has been connected and runs the
software setup again the process is
streamlined to the point where it
requires almost no interaction from the
user Beyond advancing tutorial prompts
and informational text boxes since it
has Inside Out tracking via the four
cameras on the headset the psvr2 quickly
scans and Maps the room around you which
it visualizes in a core geometric pulse
and then defines a safe play Space
taking into account any nearby objects
naturally the optimal environment for
the psvr2 is one which has a clear open
space with the freedom to move around
without bumping into things it also
needs to be a well-lit space so that the
various cameras on the headset can keep
track of your movement most people won't
be able to play in perfect conditions
however in my case I stood between my
couch and a chair positioned behind a
coffee table which amounts to about a
foot of space and my lighting came from
the bay windows during the day and a bog
standard light bulb at night despite
these less than optimal conditions I
didn't have many issues while using the
headset but after the freedom of Quest 2
being Tethered to the PlayStation 5 was
a little Annoying initially as it is
also a limiting factor on the range of
movement you have even with being able
to quickly see my surroundings I found
that part of my attention was always
dedicated to making sure I don't get too
engrossed in the game so as not to send
my console crashing To The Ground by
yanking on the wire but the trade-off is
being able to Leverage The Power of the
PlayStation 5 which has a noticeable
impact on how ambitious games can be the
only other hiccup with my less than
ideal environment happened when the
sense controllers became inconsistent
with finger tracking resulting in
strange and unexpected movements in game
this seemed more pronounced in the
evenings when there was much less
natural light it wasn't a major problem
at all it's just a bit odd to see my
virtual fingers glitching out every now
and then my favorite feature on the
psvr2 is a little button on the
underside of the headset which pauses
the game and swaps the visuals to a view
of the room you're in so you can see
your surroundings it's not a crystal
clear colored video feed and is instead
a weird night vision like view but it's
more than enough to safely walk around
the room and pick up or put down
controllers reorient yourself or as I
did check to see what level of bemuse my
cat was while watching me this is one of
those situations where the hardware
specifically the external cameras is
being smartly utilized to give the user
a better experience the whole process of
going from taking the psvr to out of the
box to playing a game takes just a few
minutes and what helps significantly is
the smooth integration into the
PlayStation ecosystem there's no need to
make new accounts or merge them as
you've probably got an existing
PlayStation account and it leverages
that as someone that went through the
ordeal of dealing with oculus accounts
Facebook requirements and migration to
matter this frictionless experience was
very much appreciated there's nothing
more to setting up the psvr than that
but where it gets complicated is the
games from the outset there's one clear
showpiece for the psvr2 that
distinguishes itself as the killer app
if you will Horizon call of the mountain
as I mentioned when I previewed the game
and the headset call of the mountain is
a reminder of how Transcendent a high
quality VR experience running on
powerful Hardware can be the technical
specifications for the headset are out
there if you want to know the
nitty-gritty of the internals but the
end result of all those bells and
whistles is that Horizon call of the
mountain is a beautiful game easily one
of the best looking VR games I've ever
seen and better still it makes effective
use of every feature the PlayStation VR2
has to some degree the OLED displays and
advanced technique such as fovea in
rendering deliver rich and vibrant
visuals that render the wall of horizon
with an overwhelming level of detail
without compromising performance psvr2
allows players to get intimate with
their environments and the Fidelity of
what you see he holds up under scrutiny
oars glide through the water trees Sway
in the wind light pierces through
outcroppings and Mountain sides are
rough and craggy being able to get up
close and personal with robotic
dinosaurs highlight some of the superb
work gorilla did with its creature
design and the same goes for fire Sprite
and its world I previously described the
feeling of being in the world of horizon
as awe-inspiring and this sensation
holds true now too that is for me the
enduring magic of Vios there's nothing
quite like the feeling of using the
sense controllers to carefully grasp
panholes to climb my way up the side of
a towering structure only to glance over
my shoulder and have the virtual world
momentarily override my sights and
senses to make me believe in the Peril
that awaited me should I take one wrong
step playing Horizon call of the
mountain makes psvr to sing and it's a
beautiful song but for as impressive as
it is eventually I couldn't help but
think about the VR experiences I had
when the technology and games first
became available and what they are now
and how little they've evolved for its
power our Horizon call of the mountain
developer fire Sprite has done an
exceptional job of taking the tried and
true gameplay ideas and mechanics that
VR has to offer and executing them
superbly in a triple a VR title call of
the mountain is virtual tourism in a
fantasy world at its most engrossing
it's one of the best climbing games I've
ever played the bow and arrow combat is
incredibly satisfying and the game even
has a story that fans of the Horizon
series will enjoy experiencing but at
the same time each of the components of
this game Exist Elsewhere in other
experiences for other devices and have
done them before many times that brings
me to the biggest challenge that psvr2
faces there's nothing that truly
distinguishes it from the competition
yes the headset is Cutting Edge and the
sense controllers with their finger
tracking capabilities are both capable
and comfortable even if they utilize in
predictable ways outside of very limited
cases mainly Half-Life Alex VR games
feel like they're trapped in the same
small box of possibilities they came in
when the rift hit the market all those
years ago there's nothing wrong with
these ideas just as there's nothing
wrong with taking existing games like
Gran Turismo or Resident Evil Village
and using a VR to open up new ways to
play them the question then becomes is
that enough for you and is that enough
if it's all it will ever be with a price
tag of 550 the cost of the PlayStation 5
it's attached to that's an important
question to ask yourself especially at
launch when psvr2 feels more like a
luxury item then a must-have gaming
platform for some spending that money to
have the latest technology is all the
justification they need but for those
that are interested in entering the
world of virtual reality in Earnest
psvr2 is a tough recommendation at the
moment as I said I enjoyed my time with
Horizon call of the mountain but no
other game made the same kind of
impression on me Kayak VR Mirage let me
paddle around a few Real World locations
during the day night and while a storm
was happening and although it was
definitely impressive to be in realistic
Recreations of locations I probably
won't visit in real life these Thrills
were are fleeting there's only so much
Furious paddling I want to do in my
leisure time cities VR let me create my
own Metropolitan Paradise by using the
sense controllers to effortlessly lay
roads erect buildings and micromanage
the day-to-day existence of my virtual
fiefdom but the process of constructing
what became my nightmare hellscape of a
city felt more novel than something I
want to return to over and over again
while I found myself missing was
something that Charmed me in the way
that astrobot did when I turned on my
PS5 for the first time or a game that
showed me something new and only
possible in a virtual reality video game
experience you might say that's a lot to
ask of PlayStation designers and
developers to create revolutionary ideas
in VR but in a crowded Market where
other some cheaper options exist that's
exactly what it needs to do if it wants
to separate itself from the pack it says
a lot that the games that I found myself
most enjoying were either old or
available in other places moss and Moss
Book 2 are utterly delightful and if
like me you let them pass you by the
first time you should Rectify that
mistake tentacular a game where you're a
kind-hearted monster with tentacles
trying to complete tasks to help out the
quirky citizens of La calma is funny and
creative it let me use the psvr2's
excellent eye tracking to interact with
characters and the sense control is to
pick up and fling objects for some
physics-based mischief and being in a
galaxy far far away in Star Wars Tales
from the Galaxy's Edge is a lot of fun
but these are all games available in
other places the hurdle of that
PlayStation and psvr2 needs to overcome
if the platform is to have a fruitful
future is ensuring that there's support
for it and not only that but giving
people a compelling case to buy it or
use it by offering exclusive and unique
experiences as it stands Horizon call of
the mountain is carrying the psvr on its
back the lineup of games that support it
will grow and there are a few games on
the way that I'm eager to play Resident
Evil Village and Resident Evil 4 remakes
VR content Chief amongst them still I
can't recommend spending the cost of an
entire gaming console for them
especially not at launch this leaves PSV
VR2 in a strange spot as a successor it
improves on what came before in every
possible way it's a very well made VR
headset that has a high quality build
and premium feel while utilizing
powerful technology and features to
ensure it hits all the markers for what
a modern VR headset should offer and it
does this while being paired with an
equally powerful console capable of
rendering or inspiring virtual spaces
but there's nothing that makes it
absolutely essential to own right now
beyond the throes of being there on day
one for new gaming Hardware or if you
just really want more Horizon what Sony
has created is a VR headset that can
exist in the space between the
affordable but underpowered Quest 2 and
the expensive but powerful index but
much of what it offers can be found on
cheaper devices like the Quest 2 which
has the added benefit of being
Standalone and wireless for enthusiasts
and people willing to push through
motion sickness like me it's very
impressive Hardware that needs more
software to actually impress them I hope
that Sony and his partner start thinking
outside of the box a bit more when it
comes to games and commit to support
avoiding the platform long term in a
meaningful way the excellent Hardware
deserves as much if they do the future
of psvr2 will be exciting but for now
that excitement is built on the same
thing that VR has always enticed
hopefuls with potential